it's 31 days of female praise yes
because it's women's History Month in
March let's salute the sex who can
handle both bleach and starch
thank you for being a girl
it's making sandwiches around the world
you deserve some praise so we gave you
about 30 days
[Music]
to celebrate your history
why don't you have yourself a beer and
some cake
[Music]
either way we just wanted to say thank
you for being a girl
[Applause]
so proud of you you go girl
I hate that phrase with every fiber of
my being yeah it's women's History Month
Kat thank you for being a woman you're
welcome well now that we got that out of
the way as corporations and groups
celebrate women you know those
mysterious creatures science can't
identify the Toronto Raptors are saying
sorry to them for this now deleted video
girls were in the world because there's
only one that came for great gave birth
everybody all women are great because
they're all queens
[Music]
so those first two players said women
are the only ones who can procreate and
birth everybody
who do those dudes think they are
biologists
where did they grow up
mad the truth they spoke pissed off a
lot of people including women that stand
up to pee
[Laughter]
you don't want to piss them off
or on the team quickly took the video
down and apologized saying it Prides
itself on doing the right thing when it
comes to inclusion and representation
meaning they're so cowardly they
literally deny their own mother which is
new we're used to pro athletes denying
who's the father
I eventually came around
[Laughter]
cat uh I go to you first because you are
a woman how are you celebrating this
month
working
excellent excellent this was great yeah
because okay I'm not a sports gal yeah
but I feel like basketball teams have a
lot more than three people on them right
right they do that was the whole video
I want to see the answers that didn't
make the cut
yes exactly probably okay but special
sensitive file
I'm dead there's okay someone's like
okay yeah they give birth the other
guy's like yeah what he said birth and
like they're like what were the guys
that were just like
like
[Applause]
what I want for women's history month is
the rest of the footage yes there's a
lot more dudes on that team yeah there
is there is what did they say do you
Tyrus do you feel bad for the athletes
who are like coerced into this crap
maybe their agent says you got to do it
you got to play ball do this no yes when
you're part of a team you have to do all
that stuff yeah same thing WWE had to do
for whatever the case was you had to do
something for one it's just part it's
part of the ridiculous salaries that we
get so it's not that the problem why
it's cut cat is those are the three
controversial ones yes those are the
ones that had the one person a gasp yeah
that sent the email in to take it down
the rest of them was like praising their
moms and like you know it's like the
whole thing it's like they do like a
Mother's Day thing where everyone Banks
everyone would think their wife or
whatever so the one again the woke on
Twitter who didn't even have tickets to
the game complained about it at home
yeah and they took it down so again
shame on you for that yeah because
thinking because I don't know how else I
don't know what else was going to birth
me but uh
um
yeah and and they should get it at least
the tip of the Hat yeah you know what
I'm saying I mean I was perfectly
willing to give my mom my birthday like
you earned it yeah you have two
birthdays you know it's a lot so the
fact that we can't honor them that
everyone in this room came from there is
ridiculous yeah
good point
hotep isn't it weird that the certain
things we have to apologize for now like
like just like straight up facts oh it's
absolutely ridiculous but you know me
I'm always going to talk about communism
this is another communist plot this one
is social obfuscation and basically
What's Happening Here is as we saw in
the past there was like this attack on
toxic masculinity attack men well the
new Target is women sort of convoluting
what it is to be a woman but really
what's Happening Here is women work
really hard for women's rights to have
women's spaces and now they're being
invaded by men right
I don't see how people don't see what's
happening this is out of all the topics
I can do calculus and all these
different crazy topics but this one I
just can't wrap my mind around and then
when you tell people about it they go oh
this is AI deep fake and it's not really
happening it's like no this is really
real this is happening but I think you
you touched on a conspiracy theory did
they choose those two
Clips because they would stir up
controversy they can use them to sort of
propel the agenda that's what I'm
wondering Hey listen stupid is as stupid
does every once in a while they'll throw
some stuff together and get it right but
yeah they like I said right now that's
the thing that's the hot spot if you're
a birthing woman somehow uh if you pee
when you stand up and wear a wig you're
you're supposed to be held in the same
Acclaim and it's not it's just not fair
you know Pete you have seven children uh
did you birth any of them
I mean no but I was there you held ice
chips right a lot of ice chips you did
the ice chips yup get the popsicle
should the WNBA celebrate men's History
Month
I don't think there is a men's history
month exactly yes
patriarchy in every month exactly every
month is is every day is men's history
month that's why but how can you have a
WNBA
yeah
wait wait no no subsidized that's why we
have subsidized but if there's no such
thing as a woman or what a woman is how
can you have a WNBA they gotta make it
all they got to make a trance but what
will yes that's the question what's
gonna happen when the first dude says
I'm transitioning and I want to be in
the WNBA and he is a scoring champ I'm
gonna make a lot of money betting on
them yeah it's a good point it's going
to be uh you are they're gonna have to
embrace it they're gonna have to embrace
it that's a great you know that's a
great movie plot two um retired NBA
players decide to go and play in the WN
what stops that transitioning and they
just decided they're watching TV and
they'll go this is crazy let's do it and
then they do it is this all was this
movie already made Juwanna Man Juwanna
Man but yeah they didn't quite
not proud that I know that movie
I never thought I would hear that movie
title again in my life we said it at the
same time so I don't even you know I
don't even know what that movie is
that's great let's just move forward all
right hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else